foreign
[Music]
I'm a rapper and I'm a MLK
a visiting scholar here at MIT
so I've done a lot I've learned how to
sail since I've been here
done a lot of karate since I've been
here the statement here at MIT is is
like trying to drink water from a fire
hose so I just kind of fully went with
that
if you just roam the Halls here and
you're attentive and you look you'll
learn a new word like every 30 steps oh
at the taxi what the hell is epitaxy
let's figure that out and then the song
I was like epitaxy okay cool crystal
growth two-dimensional crystal growth
okay and I go back to my office and like
what is up a taxi done I found myself
watching a lecture on epitaxy you know
and then you get invited over to the
biology lab and I'm in there with the
gloves and the pipettes and I'm making
bacteria do stuff and it's like you know
there's a scientist like
you know good job kind of thing and that
leads to like hey you want to do a
research paper
don't come to conference you know so
it's like you're getting pulled in all
these like really high level places by
people who are like experts in their
field and it just feels like I'm just a
rapper you know what I'm saying but it's
like no no no no you got insights into
this and we can talk about this and
build this
here are the fundamentals that I've kind
of discovered in a bunch of other MCS
and rappers have discovered can you
practice these principles and see that
they bear the fruit rap teaches a lot
is one of the most ultimate teaching
tools teaches you how to dance
teaches you how to dress
teaches you how to talk teaches you how
to walk teaches you how to think
ER it's the oldest board game in the
history of mankind it's the grandfather
of backgammon and chess it's
Mesopotamian is there a governing body
for this game
I know it's like we're gonna start it
right here at MIT so we started the
international Society of Earth this
board was manufactured here at MIT
at the hobby shop so we kind of like
updated everything just a little bit
gave a nice little carpet to sit on this
little bowl to turn around these pieces
check this out
what is going on
[Music]
oh my God I wanted it too so bad like
manufacturing boards on campus and
throwing tournaments and like giving out
prize money and making this was
hilariously crazy but expected
here at MIT it's like yeah that little
small idea that you're doing let's scale
that immediately take it all as
different places and everybody
it's like oh I can help so I'll paint
dice all night with you I'll do I'm a
manufacturer board I'll do the cad and
then she got like this nuclear physicist
doing the cad files right now you get 30
ER games going and silliness and fun and
interest and history and strategy and
chance and luck and it's like oh there's
something here deeper than just
you know they were on to something 5 000
years ago
right that's still lights up you know
The Human Condition to this day so
there's been a range of stuff man
everything that I've done here thus far
from the smallest to the biggest to the
trivial to the very very sophisticated
has been like eye-opening and mind
expanding oh he's dead
over the board
in the air
foreign